-So, yesterday,
we checked in on my old friend
the Sea Captain,
as he was making his way
through my copy
of "The Thorn Birds,"
back in the captain's quarters,
but I want to make clear
to everyone who is worried --
the Sea Captain
is not coming back.
I haven't spoken to him since
I left those captain quarters,
although, when I went
down to the bank
of the East River this morning
for my daily constitutional,
I did find this message
in a bottle
floating in the water.
And let's see here
what it says.
"Hey, Seth, what did the pirate
say to his ex-wife
when they spotted a lighthouse?
'Land, ho!'"
Jesus, man.
God help whoever he
ends up with next.
And, hey, speakin'
of needing help --
studio segue --
the president held
an old-fashioned campaign rally
in North Carolina,
as if the coronavirus pandemic
that's still raging
out of control
had just magically disappeared.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
Now is typically the time
in the political calendar
when an incumbent president
who's trailing badly
in the polls
starts to get desperate
and Donald Trump couldn't
look any more desperate
if he was crammed
into a phone booth,
beggin' for the Glengarry leads.
No human being on Earth
reeks of desperation
more than Donald Trump.
He sweats like a guy at the OTB
who bet everything on a horse
named Ol' Three Legs.
Now, we all know
that Trump doesn't just lie.
He belches out the most
outlandish lies he can think of,
especially when he's desperate.
But on Tuesday,
at a rally in North Carolina,
he managed to outdo himself
when he told his supporters
that, despite
what they can see and hear
with their own eyes and ears,
Mexico really is paying
for the dumb border wall
he didn't build.
And, honestly,
it was a real throwback,
to hear the old
Mexico border wall lie again.
It was like hearin'
"Uptown Funk" on the radio
and thinkin', "Oh, man!
I used to hear
this song at the gym.
And I used to go to the gym.
And I used to leave
my apartment. [ Chuckle ]
Uptown funk you up, indeed."
But, yeah, "Mexico's paying
for the wall" is back.
Now, to be clear, the parts
of the wall that have been built
or renovated were funded,
not by Mexico,
but by taxpayer dollars
that Congress allocated
for the Defense Department.
Trump used a national
emergency declaration
to pull funds that were
supposed to be spent
on military
construction projects,
schools and daycares,
among other things.
That money -- your money --
went to his wall.
But on Tuesday,
Trump tried to paper over that
with a new,
breathtakingly stupid lie
about how Mexico would
supposedly pay for the wall.
-And, you know, Mexico
is paying for the wall,
just so you understand.
They don't say that.
They never say it.
But we're gonna charge them
a small fee at the border,
you know, the tollbooths.
We have tollbooths.
It's the biggest border
in the world,
in terms of people
going across it,
in terms of industry,
believe it or not,
the southern border.
We're putting a small toll on
and maybe we're going to do
something with remittance.
That's where people come here,
make money,
and they send it back.
So we'll do something and we're
gonna get all the money
that we spent on the mall --
wall -- will be coming back.
-Wait, so, now,
you're gonna put tollbooths
on the southern border
and charge people a fee
when they drive across?
That's your plan?
It's one of the largest
international borders
in the world,
not the Verrazzano Bridge.
They're comin' from Mexico,
not Staten Island.
[ Laughing ]
Thank God.
[ As Trump ]
We're gonna charge 'em a toll
and no E-ZPass, folks.
We're gonna have those little,
little baskets
where you toss a coin.
You remember those.
And you have to have
the exact change.
You absolutely have
to have the exact.
And if you miss and you're
out of coins in your car,
you gotta get out of your car
and you gotta pick it up
while everyone honks at you.
We're also gonna put in some
of those coin-operated
binoculars,
so, if they miss home,
they have to pay fifty cents
to look back at Mexico.
Maybe one of those
grocery store kiddie rides.
Those guys are cash cows.
It'll add up. It'll add up.
It'll buy a wall.
Honestly, why does he
even come up
with these
elaborate explanations?
If you're gonna lie,
keep it simple.
Your hardcore fans
will believe anything.
Just have Eric come onstage
in a sombrero and fake mustache,
pretending to be
the president of Mexico,
presenting you
with a giant novelty check
for a gajillion pesos.
[ As Trump ]
Oh, look, everyone,
the president of Mexico is here.
"No, Dad.
It's me, Eric."
Oh! iIdioto!
So that's what the president was
talkin' about as the pandemic
[ Laughing ] continued
to rage outta control,
rising in at least 22 states.
Now, we know these events
have seeded outbreaks.
Trump's Tulsa rally in June
likely seeded an outbreak there,
according to the local
health director
and, yet, Trump keeps
doing them, anyway,
because he doesn't care
if people get sick.
In fact, today we learned
that he admitted
to journalist Bob Woodward
that he downplayed
the threat from the virus.
And, at the rally,
he actually expressed amazement
at how many people had come out
to his super spreader event.
-I'm thrilled to be
in Winston-Salem
with thousands of loyal,
hardworking American patriots.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You are great people.
Great people.
[ Cheering and applause
continues ]
I don't know how many people
are here, but there's a lot.
[ Cheering intensifies ]
There's a lot.
[ Whistling and applause ]
We said, "Let's keep it down."
They didn't do too good a job,
but that's good, right?
That's good.
No, these crowds, I tell ya.
It's beyond what we had,
in terms of enthusiasm,
beyond what we had
four years ago in 2016,
and that was
a record enthusiasm.
We are breaking that record
by a lot.
[ As Trump ]
It's incredible how many people
are here, chanting and yelling
and coughing in close proximity
to each other.
Also, we got a couple of beach
balls bouncin' around the crowd,
so make sure you get your hands
and your mouths on those.
Now, as we head
down the home stretch
of the presidential campaign,
we're in a moment
of acute national crisis,
unlike anything
we've seen in a century.
There are multiple crises
colliding all at once --
a raging pandemic,
an economic crash,
the collapse of our democracy,
the dismantling
of the post office,
the breakdown of the
school system,
a housing crisis,
widespread food insecurity,
extreme weather events
supercharged by climate change,
a national reckoning
over systemic racism.
There's even -- true story --
of national coin shortage.
We just didn't notice
because everyone's
too scared to use coins now.
And, when you do, you have
to wipe it down so much,
you can't even tell who's
on it anymore.
I mean, I think that's maybe
the dude from ZZ Top?
Is that you, Billy Gibbons?!
-♪ Oh, hoh hoh hoh ♪
-Oh, [bleep]
Are the graphics gonna
start talkin' now.
Hey, ZZ Top Lincoln,
what's the difference
between you in real life
and you on a penny?
-♪ Legs ♪
We have limited crew back,
but the people who say no
to jokes like that
are still out of the building.
In fact, things are so bad,
even Trump seems aware,
on some level,
that we've careened way
over the precipice
and plunged down into the abyss.
In the middle of a rant
about God knows what --
honestly, I couldn't explain it
and it's not worth trying --
he was, I guess,
telling his crowd
to imagine
what it would be like
if they return to Earth
3,000 years from now.
-If you come back
in 1,000 years,
2,000 years, or 3,000 years,
if you're lucky enough --
[ Laughing ]
assuming we have something.
The world is a crazy place,
isn't it?
-What?!
Is it slam poetry night
in the head injury ward?
Yeah, man!
We know the world is crazy.
Did you just wake up
from a four-year KFC coma?
"Last thing I remember, I was
chugging gravy out of a bucket
and then, I fell asleep
on the Trump Tower escalator."
The world is a crazy place
and you're a big reason
for that.
Trump makes everything crazy.
He's like the friend
who shows up at your place
at 3:00 am
with a vape pen, a handle
of vodka, and a duffel bag,
askin' if he can crash with you.
And then, when you're gettin'
ready for work in the morning,
he says, "Bro, you look tired."
But, in particular,
two of the simultaneous crises
we're currently dealing with
are a rapid slide into autocracy
and an out-of-control pandemic
and, in many ways,
they're related.
Like any would-be dictator,
Trump doesn't care
about the public health
response to the pandemic
or preventing the deaths
of hundreds
of thousands of Americans,
unless it benefits
him personally.
That's why he hawked
one miracle cure after another,
touted by cable pundits
and a pillow salesman
and a doctor who believes
in demon sperm.
It doesn't matter that they're
crazy or incompetent,
just that they praised him.
If Trump met a herbalist
who complimented his tie,
he'd show up to his next
press conference
with some tinctures and sage.
[ As Trump ]
Alright, everyone,
we're gonna smudge the room
and then drink
some honeysuckle extract
while holding one
of these crystals.
They're just rocks I dug up
in the Rose Garden.
We're calling 'em
crystals, though.
In fact, Trump is, once again,
desperately hoping
for a coronaviruses
silver bullet
to revive his
political fortunes.
He's pressuring the CDC and FDA
to approve a coronavirus
vaccine before November,
despite the fact that experts
have said that's unlikely.
And, yet, on Monday,
Trump announced
that a vaccine could be
ready by October,
which just happens to be right
before the election.
-Under my leadership,
we'll produce a vaccine
in record time.
'Cause, now, they see
we've done an incredible job,
and in speed like nobody's
ever seen before.
This could've taken two
or three years
and, instead, it's going
to be -- [ Laughs ]
it's gonna be done
in a very short period of time.
Could even have it
during the month of October.
-Oh! October.
How convenient.
He's like an inveterate gambler
who's in deep with a loan shark.
"I quit gambling
and I can get you your money.
You just gotta give me until the
day after the Kentucky Derby.
Don't let me down again,
Ol' Three Legs!"
And, look, we all desperately
want a vaccine
as soon as humanly possible,
but we want it
to be safe and effective,
so enough people will get it
and we can put
this nightmare behind us.
Unfortunately,
the way Trump is going,
he's gonna start handin' out
vials of Diet Coke
at his rallies,
labeled "vaxine."
Trump sees no distinction
between the government
and his personal interests.
America's slide into autocracy
and the administration's
horrific response
to the coronavirus pandemic
are related crises.
Aspiring dictators like Trump
only care about what serves
their interests.
Trump and the GOP are
an authoritarian movement
and, in a functioning democracy,
the people responsible
for this crisis
would be banished
from power for...
-1,000 years, 2,000 years,
or 3,000 years.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪